au nord d'idiome cette forêt semble
encore plus triste sous la neige
des centaines de tombes et une fausse
commune qui ont été découverte après le
retrait des forces russes de nombreux
corps portaient des traces de torture
dans la ville les Russes n'ont laissé
que des ruines des mois de bombardements
et de combat ont tout détruit
même l'hôpital n'a pas été épargné toute
une aile dévastée voici ce qui reste des
salles d'opération
le docteur Yuri couznetsov un chirurgien
de 53 ans ne cache pas sa lassitude
après un an de guerre
physiquement ça va nous dit-il mais
émotivement avec tous ces gens qui
meurent toutes ces tragédies on ne peut
pas aller bien
il nous emmène voir le sous-sol c'est là
sous le nez des Russes et malgré la peur
qu'il a continué d'opérer jour et nuit
pendant l'occupation les patients
étaient installés le long du mur
il faisait très froid dit-il 1 à 3
degrés les gens avaient plusieurs
couvertures sur eux il a ainsi pu sauver
bien des gens à l'étage les soins ont
repris
Galina olexandina 71 ans a été opérée
pour une fracture multiple elle va mieux
aujourd'hui mais une autre blessure
prendra plus de temps à guérir
en mars dernier l'immeuble ou ses
enfants habitaient a été bombardé son
fils ses filles ses petits-enfants tous
ont péri 8 vies fauchées d'un coup
regardez-moi
vous pouvez imaginer comme mère nous
dit-elle j'étais anéantie mais j'ai dû
rester forte car il fallait les enterrer
elle nous parle sans émotion le choc est
trop grand dans une chambre voisine à
l'extender collisning se remet de
l'amputation de sa jambe le mois dernier
il a sauté sur une mine en allant porter
des jouets et de la nourriture à des
enfants dans le besoin est-ce que
c'était une mine russe
elle pouvait venir de n'importe où
dit-il en fait c'est peut-être une
minutrinienne qui est en a aussi utilisé
des milliers il se demande quand est-ce
que tout ça va finir personne dit-il ne
le sait
[Musique]
des patients comme à l'exender le
docteur cosnetzov envoie de plus en plus
chaque semaine dit-il certaines régions
sont déminées mais il reste énormément
de munitions non-explosées et les gens
peuvent marcher dessus n'importe quand
la vie a repris lentement à isium mais
les effets de la guerre demeurent et au
moment où on redoute une nouvelle
offensive de l'ennemi on se demande où
les Ukrainiens pourront puiser le
courage de passer à travers une deuxième
année de souffrance ici Céline Galipeau
Radio-Canada is you